okay hi everyone um so I'm jalani Nelson
and I'm talking I'm going to talk to you
about a program a summer program that
will
uh next summer summer 2024 called
sublinear algorithms and this is a
program that uh we're organizing jointly
between the seven of us on this
slide uh program details it runs from
May 20th to August 9th in
2024 um and we already have if you look
on our website I think 29 people listed
as long-term participants and if if any
of you want to join I think the
application is still open okay
um some of the themes streaming
algorithms and sketching algorithms uh
sublinear time algorithms such as
property testing local algorithms which
is also closely related to sublinear
time local distributed algorithms
massively parallel computation and
distribution testing especially
sublinear time distribution
testing um we're gonna have four
workshops throughout the
summer uh the first is the boot camp
which will be five days of tutorial
presentations on the topics that I
showed on the last slide
um that's in the very beginning of the
program the next thing is a workshop
called extroverted sublinear algorithms
okay and this is looking at um sublinear
algorithm applications of sublinear
algorithms you know in applied domains
but also applications of sublinear
algorithms to other areas of computer
science like to other areas of algorithm
design machine learning Etc so for
example um Aaron talked about one of the
programs that's happening right now and
um one of the things that's happening
right now in this program is
optimization is one of the focuses and
we've seen sketching and streaming
algorithms being used as a tool design
to design better uh algorithms for flow
and linear
programming um so extroverted is looking
outward with sublinear
algorithms sublinear graph
simplification will be the next Workshop
talking about things like uh graph
sparsifiers and banners using random
walks for spectral partitioning
regularity lemas
Etc and the final Workshop which will
just be a few days after that will be uh
the work wola workshop on local
algorithms which is a workshop that
usually happens annually um even when
there is no Simons program on some
linear algorithms but this will be part
of it this time and this will focus on
the local algorithms that I mentioned so
local algorithms are sublinear
algorithms which uh compute just a part
of the output at only a a sublinear part
of the input okay so that's all I have
for you
thanks